all right really excited to share with
you a new feature in collimator that
incorporates gpt4 to generate block
diagrams and Analysis scripts that you
can use from a text prompt so in this
first example the user is essentially
typing in a paragraph that they want a
second order system representing a
spring math damper with some particular
parameters
gpt4 generates the code generates the
block diagram and of course you can
visualize the different components look
at the code at General generates and
plot the system responses for example
the step response and you can also ask
it things like to generate the equations
of motion or to replace the system with
a different kind of system
so really really very flexible kind of
text-based inquiry rapid design this is
way faster than you'd be able to do it
just by dragging and dropping and kind
of going to Wikipedia again because all
of that Corpus of knowledge is directly
kind of being accessed by this chat
model
so really really useful to do things
like you know wrap a PID controller
around that system
for the next example in Signal
processing we are going to generate some
discrete time data okay with a given
frequency and kind of carrier signal and
perform some tasks like amplitude
modulation and things like that so you
know really really simple it creates the
module you could look at the code and
execute
you can compute the plot the amplitude
modulated signal I think it's kind of
cool that chat knows that am is
amplitude modulation in this context
um you can plot you know the power
Spectra you can look at the code
um really really flexible approach to
um
kind of generating these block diagrams
just from basic text you can plot the
noise spectrum and all of this is
generating collimator code and Analysis
scripts on the back end that you again
you could copy these into other scripts
you could use these in the future but
you can also interact with this in real
time you can ask questions that you
might have to go to Wikipedia to find
the answers to and it will kind of tell
you from its best uh you know Corpus of
knowledge how to do these various types
of analysis and Signal processing
so really just an incredible capability
here to massively massively streamline
the design and modeling process so try
it out yourself at collimator.ai